everybody I just made a couple notes
first of all I want to thank my family
my friends the incredible people of
Chicago and all over the country in the
world who have prayed for me who have
supported me who've shown me so much
love no one will ever know how much that
has meant to me and I will forever be
grateful I want you to know that not for
a moment was it in vain
I've been truthful and consistent on
every single level since day one I would
not be my mother's son if I was capable
of one drop of what I was accused of
this has been an incredibly difficult
time honestly one of the worst of my
entire life but I am a man of faith and
I'm a man that has knowledge of my
history and I would not bring my family
our lives or the movement through a fire
like this
I just wouldn't so I want to thank my
legal counsel from the bottom of my
heart and I would also like to thank the
state of Illinois for attempting to do
what's right now I'd like nothing more
than to just get back to work and move
on with my life but make no mistakes I
will always continue to fight for the
justice equality and betterment of
marginalized people everywhere so again
thank you for all the support thank you
for faith and thank you too god bless
y'all thank you very much
[Music]
[Music]